Dice resuelve la desigualdad para "c"
y gráfica la solución.
Tenemos -5c menor o igual que 15,
lo voy a escribir acá un poco más grande,
y si queremos resolver
esta desigualdad para "c",
simplemente tenemos que aislar a la "c"
¡Ajá!
En este momento tenemos
que está siendo
multiplicada por este -5
y la mejor manera de tener a la "c"
en el lado izquierdo, a ella sola,
es multiplicando
a ambos lados de la desigualdad,
por el inverso multiplicativo de -5,
eso es -1/5 entonces
multiplicamos
-1/5 por -5c
y -1/5 por 15,
15 por -1/5
simplemente estoy multiplicando aquí
por el inverso multiplicativo de -5
y de esta manera,
al multiplicarlo nos queda la "c" sola.
Ahora bien aquí no dibuje el signo de menor o igual porque debemos recordar
que si estamos multiplicando o dividiendo a ambos lados de una desigualdad por un número negativo
debes voltear el signo de desigualdad,
ajá, y es justo lo que estoy haciendo aquí,
porque
estamos aquí
multiplicando por este -1/5
y es lo mismo
que dividir por -5 entonces
este menor o igual
se convierte a un mayor o igual
y ya resolvamos
la desigualdad para "c".
Tenemos -1/5 multiplicado por -5
eso es igual a 1,
así que el lado izquierdo
nos queda simplemente "c"
es mayor o igual que
15 multiplicado por -1/5,
es lo mismo que 15 dividido por -5,
eso es igual a -3,
así que la solución es
"c" mayor o igual que -3.
Y ahora grafiquemos esto,
grafiquemos la solución,
voy a dibujar aquí una recta numérica,
aquí voy a poner al 0, al -1,
-2 y -3,
y de este lado voy a poner al 1 y al 2.
Entonces "c"
es mayor o igual que -3,
así que nos dice que puede ser el -3,
voy a llenar ese espacio
y como es mayor o igual que -3
es todo esto también,
todo, todo esto va a seguir hasta infinito.
Así que todo lo que sea mayor a -3,
eso va a funcionar,
de hecho puedes verificarlo, escoge...
vamos a escoger
un número que funcione,
por ejemplo,
el 0 deberá funcionar.
Verifiquemos eso,
-5 por 0 es igual a 0
y 0 es menor o igual que 15,
de hecho es menor que 15,
entonces si funciona.
Ahora intentémoslo con un número
que está fuera de la solución,
entonces -4 por 5,
eso es igual a 20
y 20 no es menor o igual que 15,
así que por eso no está en la solución,
porque no funciona,
a todos los números
mayores o igual que -3
esos sí funcionan,
de hecho puedes intentarlo
con cualquier número mayor o igual que -3,
inténtalo y diviértete.